[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh he's the champ
he's who everybody thought would
probably win the bracket challenge the
drummer for young the giant francois
cometois hopefully i got that uh how did
i do with my french
that was a i'd give it a 95 okay all
right
yeah we don't aim for perfection around
here uh congrats on winning the bracket
challenge uh you had baylor beating
gonzaga in the national title game
you also had connecticut going to the
final four as well francois so
do you know college basketball uh
i would say i have a glancing knowledge
of college basketball actually
the reason i i won and the reason i put
uconn in
the final four were both because of my
brother-in-law who did go to uconn
he gave me good advice on the on the
championship game and not such good
advice for the final four
um is there going to be a song off this
win
are you are you going to be able to
write something off winning the bracket
challenge here
yeah i mean i think just touching on
these feelings of uh
surprise i actually thought i was in
last place as of yesterday morning
and then someone pointed out that i
hadn't paid attention i did so poorly
for the rest of it and then i
realized that i actually picked the
right two teams for the uh the finals
but
um yeah i mean i think it's definitely
sparked some ideas
uh how are you gonna did you celebrate
last night
like a rock star i had a couple beers
and i went to bed at uh
9 45
but did you used to have a time where
you acted like a
you know like a tour bus days and hotel
rooms yeah well i mean
we haven't toured in about a year so uh
it's
i kind of forget those days but yeah
definitely when we were starting out in
the
in the early 20s there were some some
late nights uh in early mornings and
early morning calls where you regretted
the late nights but
um we've slowed down a little bit and uh
you're from canada
yeah i was born in montreal okay and uh
you how did you guys come up with young
the giant
we we tried to change we had an original
name from when we were a high school
band and
you know we wanted to do something
different and just kind of threw
everything at the wall and that was the
one that stuck
and in retrospect it's about the most
difficult thing to
pronounce um so i don't know that it was
a great name but
uh we're sticking with it did you uh
ever meet the canadian
best canadian drummer of all time neil
pert yeah
i i unfortunately i didn't have the
chance but um i'm a huge fan and
it was a big loss for the the canadian
family definitely
well congratulations when do you guys
get back in studio or when do you guys
start to tour again
we've actually been taking advantage of
the the year um to write
and record so we're hopefully going to
have a fifth record within the next few
months
and then shows are starting to pick up
again so we have some
uh shows coming up in april and then a
few festivals throughout the summer and
then hopefully we can do some more
uh you know deep touring in 2022. well
we hope that you'll uh
be in the bracket challenge next year as
the defending champ
i i mean i think i have to at this point
this is definitely a perfect example of
beginner's luck
and this is what happened in my my
fantasy hoops league i won the first
year
i am in last place this year so uh
winning the bracket
kind of helped me balance it out if you
can stay on hold we'd like to get uh
your address to send you some
dp show gear oh cool yeah sounds good uh
francois thank you and uh
congratulations thanks appreciate it
that's uh
francois contoir the drummer for young
the giants i think i'm 95
uh yeah there